welcome back to another episode of
bigquery spotlight
today we're talking about bigquery data
governance
so that everyone in your organization
can easily find
and leverage the data they need to make
effective decisions
while minimizing overall risk and
ensuring regulatory compliance
let's jump in
[Music]
the term data governance is thrown
around quite a bit
but what does it actually mean data
governance is everything you do
to ensure your data is secure private
accurate available and usable inside of
bigquery
for us governance starts during data
onboarding
let's say your team has received a new
request
someone from your e-commerce department
wants to add transactions data
into a new bigquery table the first step
in ensuring governance is understanding
the data
for example figuring out where the data
is coming from
and what information it contains in this
case the transactions will be extracted
from a database
and you already know the schema so let's
start by creating a new blank bigquery
table
next you'll need to make sure that
sensitive data is protected
to do so you'll want to categorize the
information in your new table
for example marking specific columns as
having personally identifiable
information
you might remember that tables can have
labels
while labels are a great way to easily
categorize bigquery objects
they are a bit limited and can't be used
for specific columns
lucky for us bigquery has deep
integrations with data catalog
google cloud's data discovery and
metadata management service
data catalog automatically tracks
technical metadata for bigquery assets
so we can already find our new bigquery
table
and see things like column names
descriptions and when it was created
but the really cool part is that you can
create schematized tags that act as
annotations to capture metadata
we've already created a tag template
that tracks data governance information
so now let's fill it in and attach the
tag to the email column
great now we're tracking that this
entity contains customer email addresses
but you might also notice there's a
comments column
that stores free form text customers
have added to their order
there's a chance that some of these rows
contain more sensitive information
this is where dlp comes in dlp
or cloud data loss prevention is google
cloud service designed to help you
discover
and protect your most sensitive data
with dlp you can create an inspection
job that scans comments for email
addresses
dlp can scan data that lives in data
store google cloud storage
or bigquery and can send you an
email with the scan results save the
results back to a table inside of
bigquery
or even write the results directly into
data catalog
many bigquery users choose to leverage
an orchestration tool
like cloud composer to build data
onboarding pipelines
for example you might load your
transactions data
in a lockdown staging project inside of
bigquery
and kick off a dlp scan when new
comments are added
the results will be listed in the
staging table's metadata
inside of data catalog if the scan shows
that any sensitive information
is included in a comment then you can
also kick
off a de-identification workflow where
dlp
replaces pii with something like an
asterisk
or a hash symbol then the new data is
finally appended
to the production bigquery table
now that you've de-identified and
classified your data
you're ready to design access policies
to understand data access in bigquery
you need to familiarize yourself with
identity access management
or iam if you haven't already
watched our video on bigquery iam i
recommend
pausing and taking a look we've linked
it in the comments below
great so on to data sharing
when it comes to granting access to
bigquery data
many administrators choose to grant
google groups representing your
company's different departments access
to specific data sets or projects
so policies are simple to manage
say you have a project that stores your
organization's e-commerce data
you might give the e-commerce team the
bigquery data viewer role
in this project now someone on the
e-commerce team
needs data from a different team like
the product development department
you may be inclined to just grant them
access to that data set
instead you could use an authorized view
or an authorized udf
so that your ecommerce analyst can get
limited access to product data
while still keeping more manageable team
to project permissions
so this all sounds great but what about
those pii
columns that we flagged before in data
catalog
you definitely don't want the ecom team
to have access to those
unless they have special clearance from
security
with bigquery you can control access to
specific columns
using policy tags from data catalog
here we've created a taxonomy which
classifies the level of clearance needed
to access different types of data
anyone who needs access to our highly
sensitive data
should be added as a fine-grained reader
to the high resource
so in our case we'll just add the ecom
pii
clearance group next we can apply these
as policy tags to columns in our
bigquery table
marking the columns with pii as highly
sensitive
and to take it one step further maybe
you don't want
all e-commerce folks to get access to
the transactions data
instead each analyst should only be able
to view
transactions for the product category
they work on
you can control access to specific rows
in bigquery using a row-level access
policy
like the one we're showing here between
storing data in different containers and
leveraging
authorized views udfs policy tags and
row-level access policies
you have a lot of options for sharing
data in a secure manner
check out the documentation below for
some more guidance on pros and cons
and general best practices for policy
access
okay so we've onboarded our data set and
we've shared it
the last step we'll talk about is
ongoing monitoring
including ensuring that data is accurate
this is where data quality comes in
there are lots of different tools
that allow you to declare quality
validation tests
by writing custom assertions using sql
for example you may want to check and
make sure that you don't have any
duplicate entries
in your table we've actually created an
open source framework for data quality
validation
that's included in the comments below
and keep an
eye out for data form our tool for
developing sql pipelines
which will be open to new customers soon
just like we mentioned before you can
use an orchestration tool like cloud
composer
to programmatically run these tests and
alert you if something seems wrong
you can also use the data catalog api to
make sure that quality metadata
is added to tags and is easily
discoverable
[Music]
aside from monitoring quality you might
also want to monitor
who's accessing the data and how they're
using it
well you're in luck in a few weeks we're
diving into monitoring your bigquery
deployment
so be sure to tune in and remember stay
curious
[Music]
[Music]
you